mir ist durch den kopf gegangen ist ja
auf der einen seite erfreulich dass sich
die politik das ganze land nach den
späten stillstands jahren von angela
merkel langsam in bewegung setzt und die
drei parteien der mutmaßlich kommenden
ampel koalition sprechen von aufbruch
und fortschritt fortschritt ist ein
tolle toller begriff der jahrzehnte
gebraucht worden ist jetzt ist er wieder
während in den talkshows den politischen
von ard und zdf wo das ganze jahr
gespiegelt werden soll dieser aufbruch
der eben nicht festzustellen ist da das
schöpft man sich in in stillstand und
und routine was auch kein wunder ist
wenn man eher hinguckt also maybrit
illner moderiert ihre sendung seit 22
jahren
plasberg wird seine sendung seit 20
jahren und selbst eine bild ist schon
seit 14 jahren im talk da
glaube ich habe manchmal schon die
schönheitschirurgen mehr zu tun als die
als
befruchtenden redakteure jedenfalls es
gibt zwei von den forschern die sich
selbst erneuert haben in ihrem
fortschritt das ist sandra maischberger
und
was gibt es da zu lachen
dann habe ich das sofort direkt mit dem
ausdruck größten bedauerns jedenfalls
aber wer sagt dass ich nicht mal männer
rede
egal wir wollen diese wollen jetzt von
dieser schiene wegkommen sandra
maischberger und
der kollege lanz haben sich in ihren
sendungen selbst erneuert das ist schon
eine erstaunliche geschichte sozusagen
bei rollenden rädern die räder
gewechselt markus lanz hat es
fertiggebracht sich vom charme bolzen so
ein kettenhund das so will ich das nicht
sagen der ist ein spezielles verhör
spezialist exakt das wollte ich auch
sagen das ist ein völliger wandel seines
bildes in in seiner talkshow während die
anderen weiter in langeweile versinken
und das tun was man halt so tut und ich
glaube wenn jetzt das land
insgesamt aufbricht was ich hoffe dann
sollten ard und zdf in diesen formaten
auch endlich anfangen aufzubrechen das
heißt neue köpfe in den talk sendungen
neue konzepte und formate und neue
sendetermine und da sage ich nur ard und
zdf da seid ihr doch gut genug für oder
oder schafft er das nicht mehr und ich
finde das so recht ich glaube man muss
das problem sogar größer fassen es geht
nicht nur um die fehlende
weiterentwicklung bei talkshows sondern
meiner ansicht nach um shows am abend im
fernsehen allgemein ard und zdf liefern
eigentlich nur noch alte ware ab die sie
aber als neu verkaufen jetzt kommt wo
werden dass mein gott und das wird uns
als große innovation 58 wohl darauf
freut sich jeder drauf wurde natürlich
serie hat das ist doch ein kleiner sowie
der familie wieso kindern ja aber einmal
magazin aber du willst dich immer auf
das was schon mal gab das ist ja keine
neue idee das ist einfach eine sehr gute
idee die immer wieder hervorgekramt wird
oder giovanna giovanni zarella schon
eine große musikshow auch das ist nicht
weltbewegendes wenn du wirklich wirklich
neues sehen willst im fernsehen musst du
sehr sehr lange suchen und die ideen
kommen meistens nicht aus deutschland
sondern aus dem ausland aus japan kam
zum beispiel last one love ich weiß
nicht ob er das kennt oder so maaß
single kam aus südkorea sensationelle
schoss aber nichts davon haben sich
deutsch ausgedacht es wurden auch nicht
aus deutschland denn da altern mit ihrem
publikum und das publikum alt hat immer
weiter und ich weiß nicht gleich sehen
glaube ich immer weniger überhaupt
öffentlich rechtliches fernsehen die
sind in ganz anderen medien unterwegs
die jungen und ich muss mal hier zu
diesem format sagen dieses hier wo jeder
gast sein eigenes thema mitbringt kann
das mit seinen worten vorstellen und
hinterher wird diskutiert das gibt es ja
kein zweites mal im deutschen fernsehen
und zwar nirgendwo 12 monate das ist da
aber das ist ich sage immer das ist ein
reich der freiheit was man aus
öffentlich-rechtlichen talkshows nicht
mehr gewöhnt ist da wird man vorher
erstmal eine dreiviertel stunde
vernommen was man überhaupt einen land
was man denkt und sagt und dann wird
erwogen ob man in irgendeine
inszenierung reinpasst und hier wird
nicht inszeniert hier sagt jeder was er
will obwohl ich muss hier eine lanze
brechen ich war ja im april war ich bei
sandra maischberger ein gelage und
sandra maischberger hat mir ab wo ich
vor ort war das gefühl gegeben ist
eigentlich völlig egal was ich sage wer
ganz toll dass ich da wenn sie hat also
ich bin ganz großer fan von sandra
maischberger seit ich in der sendung von
ihr war und ich finde dass sie wenn ich
habe dort hart gegen die grünen aus
geteilt ist mit euch nicht jemandem
öffentlich-rechtlichen runden gefallen
haben sandra maischberger hat in keiner
einzigen sekunde menschliches gefühl
gegeben ganz anders klasse schon
großartige trocknet aus ihr schon
richtig ich bin nach hause gefahren und
habe im auto gedanke irgendwann wäre ich
gerne wissen wie sandra maischberger
also da muss ich durch eine lanze
versuchen er
will ja auch vor der sendung auch
telefonisch einvernommen worden ja ich
nehme an mindestens eine halbe stunde
und wenn sich hinterher redaktion
herausgestellt hätte dass das nicht
richtig passt mit den anderen gästen
dann wärst du 14 tage später eingeladen
worden das sind halt inszenierungen wir
hier stellen erst an dem abend fest ob
es überhaupt zusammenpassen über ob
übereinander herfallen und ab sonst
duzen oder siezen so ob das ob das
fröhlich zugeht oder nicht und wir haben
hier einfach spannende köpfe ein und wer
mit wie axt und das ist natürlich auch
dieses format wo der gast was mitbringt
ist natürlich im prinzip auch eine
vorlage für öffentlich-rechtliches
fernsehen aber die wollen halt da darf
nichts schiefgehen es muss alles ganz
sicher eruiert sein und leidenschaft in
einer sendung dass man sich mal streitet
dass sich zwei gäste richtig streiten
die bekommen dann gesagt machen sie es
bitte nach der sendung weiter und als
willst aber in der sendung sehen ja aber
es in talkshows eigentlich so dankbar
weil sie so günstig zu produzieren sind
und das ist ja auch immer
für alle da sich überhaupt noch
abzuheben denn wenn wir ehrlich sind im
fiktionalen bereich kann man ja nichts
mehr gewinnen ging max und co also man
muss eigentlich schon in talkshows
investieren und was ja auch schwierig
ist es eigentlich dann bleiben die am
ende nur noch krimis mit regionalem
bezug über weil was wir sonst machen
ja das trio ich gebe was peinlich genug
den bergdoktor manchmal ganz gern und
ich glaube auch herz kino ganz gerne
unter anderem rosamunde pilcher jetzt
bin ich wirklich richtig nervös
die habe ich das hier gut mutig mit
ihrem mann
wenigsten strom also irgendwo zu hause
seine bücher nämlich auch irgendwie
meine kindheit deswegen aber hat er
gesehen wie das denn gibt's irgendwas
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk zum
beispiel rosamunde pilcher bowie fan von
bin oder den portugiesen meischberger
was sie gerne schauen fußball
länderspiele im öffentlich-rechtlichen
ich schlage man warten wurde das würde
er gerne gucken das heißt
grenzpatrouille und da kann man uns die
spannendsten sachen sehen das kandieren
natürlich kannte warum warum sind das
immer mordkommissionen die überall rum
laufen ich meine an der grenze wird auch
gemordet gelegentlich oder menschen
kommen ums leben aber jedenfalls eine
spannende geschichte ist wären wir ja
noch hören es gibt hier eine doku gsg 9
die war ganz interessant aber in der tat
also als polizeilich ist passiert da
tatsächlich wenig oder sage ich
vergleiche sie sind auch kein fan der
öffentlich rein ich absolut wir würden
hier herr jörges bei flächen aber
solider leistung absolut absolut außer
fußball und markus lanz ist nicht viel
viel mehr also um einen gut gebauten hat
ja ja ja dann habe er jedoch nicht aus
dem hause bank denen den schätzen sie
schon den öffentlich rechtlichen auftrag
den öffentlich rechtlichen auftrag
selbstverständlich da muss ja auch der
muss ja auch da ist auch im radio da
sein aber mit mit augenmaß also die wahl
zu haben öffentlich rechtlich oder
privat auch schon das ist denke ich ganz
wichtig denn die polizei immer gut
vertreten in dem ganzen
team polizeiliche themen werden nicht
immer von den öffentlich-rechtlichen so
aufgenommen wie wir es gerne hätten
immer nur barca manager da ist man eher
bei denen bei den privaten besser
aufgehoben siehst du bist dein urteil
zwischen öffentlich-rechtliche die
öffentlich rechtliche fernsehen hat mich
weitestgehend verloren und wir waren ja
auch beim thema jetzt ganz neue formate
erneuerungen wenn man in cannes für neue
köpfe die funk formate anschaut die auf
youtube publikum zielen wieder viel geld
ausgegeben wird es gibt es ja seit fünf
jahren wo ich anfangs dachte als das
gestartet ist na klar man will jetzt an
die junge zielgruppe ran muss ja auch
sagen man muss da hin wo die zuschauer
sind da wird die politik den leuten
näher gebracht aber wir wissen dass hat
wenn wir uns das anschauen diese formate
ist jetzt gerade auch viel analysiert
worden das hatten schon eine links-grüne
schlagseite relativ eindeutig da werden
die grünen wähler von morgen
herangezogen das ist nicht das also wenn
ich daran denke dass die dann irgendwie
ins hauptprogramm nachrücken damit ist
mir dann nicht gedient aber ehrlich
gesagt ich stelle mir immer vor dass die
formate wie wir sie heute kennen diese
talkshows die haben dann über eine
längere zeit der dann unterstellen wir
mal existierten regierung
koalitionsregierung haben dies mit den
interessantesten figuren zu tun die
kommen nach meiner wahrnehmung aus fdp
und grünen während die spd daraus mal
gucken wie die überhaupt anfängt die
haben mit welchen leuten aber kann ja
noch was werden aber die beiden sind die
interessantesten auch dass die
zusammenarbeiten ist ja so wahnsinnig
interessant werde dann das vorher für
möglichkeiten und die sitzen dann in
diesen talkshows wo die moderatoren seit
ewigen zeiten die linie vertreten haben
das grün und gelb spinnefeind sind und
eigentlich nichts miteinander zu tun
haben und dann wenn die dann mit denen
reden reden die sowohl sei das normal
dass die jetzt miteinander zu tun haben
und das geht eben nicht da müssen da
müssen und auch moderatoren sitz und
gäste sitzen die nachvollziehen können
warum das so ist wir wissen ja dass
viele junge leute grün und gelb gewählt
haben da ist darüber diskutiert worden
warum das eigentlich so ist dann müssen
aber leute sitzen die nicht nur die
frage stellen sondern die sie auch
beantworten und das bedeutet natürlich
dass in den talk sendungen ein bisschen
anders gedacht wird als bisher aber das
ist ja ganz oft was zuschauer sich
fragen oder ich habe auch schon viele
zuschriften nach meinem letzten buch zu
bekommen ist der öffentlich-rechtliche
rundfunk denn eigentlich grün links ist
es so dass da diese schlagseite ist du
hast ja gerade angesprochen sind bastian
zu kämpfen ist es auch so es gibt auch
gegenbeispiele es gibt dieter nuhr der
dann ja auch bei twitter reichlich für
shitstorm sorgt weil er eben nicht so
drauf ist sondern mal aus der
gegenrichtung kommt aber insgesamt ich
habe neulich mal wieder tagesschau
geschaut irgendwie mal so wie früher
oder heute journal wo ich dachte also
was liebedienerei bericht über angela
merkel und ich dachte menschen
dass das scheint doch gar nicht oder das
ist doch bisschen warum warum so liebe
dienerin auch mal kritisch mit ihrem
eine kritische bilanz nach all den
jahren
es gibt ja genug um fragen die das
bestätigen die nina das ist eine
eindeutige schlagseite gibt ich glaube
die letzte die ich gelesen habe war aus
der nachrichtenredaktion der tagesschau
die irgendwie dass gleich die zahlen
nicht genau
habe werde ich sie auch nicht irgendwer
finden wo sich jedenfalls herausgestellt
hat dass eine deutliche mehrheit grün
selbst grün wählt und dass die fdp und
die union der verschwindend kleine
minderheit in der redaktion haben das
ist so vielleicht nicht beim bayerischen
rundfunk das würde ich mal unterstellen
dass das dann nicht so ist dass er
umgekehrt aber jedenfalls gut ist es
nicht und man sieht ja immer wieder wie
es in der nachrichten geben durchsickert
und vor allem in wahlzeiten ist das so
dann in bestimmte sachen nicht gemeldet
und anteil groß gespielt also ich guck
mal nach berlin ja wir wissen alle wie
diese wahl kürzlich hier schief gelaufen
ist da ist schon darüber berichtet
worden in den berliner medien aber gibt
es dann aufschrei einen bleibenden in
den berliner medien die sagen das wollen
wir doch bitte noch mal machen dieser
wahl und zwar so wie sie stimmt gibt es
nicht
[Musik]